MIGHT.
TRACE GALLAGHER, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
AS YOU SAW ON TAPE, NORTHAM
CAME OUT IN FAVOR OF
INFANTICIDE THIS WEEK.
NOT EXAGGERATING.
NORTHAM SAID IT SLOWLY AND
CLEARLY.
YOU JUST SAW IT.
THEN HE REITERATED HIS VIEWS
IN CASE HE WASN'T CLEAR THE
FIRST TIME.
TODAY IN A STATEMENT HE SAID
ABORTION OF ANY STAGE THIS IS
A POSITIVE GOOD -- LISTEN TO
THIS CAREFULLY.
BECAUSE "REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM
LEADS TO ECONOMIC FREEDOM."
IN OTHER WORDS, ABORTION IS
VIRTOUS BECAUSE IT MAKES WOMEN
EFFICIENT EMPLOYEES, BETTER
AND MORE DUTIFUL SERVANTS OF
NORTHAM DONORS.
THEY CAN WORK LONGER HOURS
WITHOUT WORRYING ABOUT ANYBODY
BUT THEIR BOSSES.
HE IS IN FAIR OF THAT AS IS
THE DEMOCRATS THAT SERVE THEIR
OWN MASTER IN THE PRIVATE
EQUITY CLASS.
BUT THE PRESS COVERED THIS.
BUT THE REPORTER OF THE
"WASHINGTON POST" THE REAL
CRIME IS REPUBLICANS
COMPLAINING ABOUT RALPH
NORTHAM.
"ABORTION BILL DRAWS G.O.P.
OUTRAGE AGAINST RALPH NORTHAM,
DEMOCRATIC LEGISLATORS."
THAT IS A HEADLINE.
REPUBLICANS WHINE TOO MUCH.
INFANTICIDE, NOT A BIG DEAL.
THEN ALL OF THAT CHANGED YOU
HEARD TODAY.
THE FIRST DAY OF BLACK HISTORY
MONTH.
BIG LEAGUE POLITICS UNCOVERED
THE PHOTO TRACE JUST TOLD US
ABOUT.
WHAT IS SO INTERESTING ABOUT
IT IS THAT RALPH NORTHAM SPENT
A LOT OF HIS LAST CAMPAIGN
CALLING HIS OPPONENT RACIST.
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN.
THE CLOSING FLURRY OF THE
CAMPAIGN WAS ADS PUTTING UP
THE REPUBLICAN OPPONENT UP
AGAINST PICTURES WHAT HAPPENED
AT CHARLOTTESVILLE.
ATROCITIES OF CHARLOTTESVILLE.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT THE
OPPONENT WAS RACIST BUT
NORTHAM SAID 9 A LOT.
STRIKINGLY NORTHAM'S OPPONENT
NEVER TOOK PICTURE OF HIMSELF
IN BLACKFACE OR A KLAN ROBE.
SO THERE IS IRONY OF THE
STORY.
AS OF NOW, A NUMBER OF
PROMINENT DEMOCRATS KAMALA
HARRIS AMONG THEM, CALLED FOR
NORTHAM RESIGNATION AMONG
THIS.
THERE ARE MANY IN HIS PARTY,
PARTICULARLY IN VIRGINIA,
STANDING BY HIM.
THEY PERSONALLY OPPOSE
BLACKFACE AND CLAP ROBES BUT
THEY DON'T WANT THEM RELEGATED
TO THE BLACK ALLEY.
THEY WANT THEM SAFE, LEGAL AND
RARE.
PRIVATE MATTER BETWEEN A
POLITICIAN AND HIS DONORS.
FOR NOW, GOVERNOR NORTHAM WILL